hi thanks for waking up
uh
and trekking through the rain
yeah so what i'll talk about today is
doing work with jian ding and duval
paris it was it was done mostly in
seattle where it's actually a beautiful
sunny day today
at least according to the my security
camera
okay so actually i want to talk about
work that's uh that we did a few years
ago
but the reason i'm going to talk about
is
because uh well for some reason
uh
okay people in this program should know
about it but uh
uh they still seem uh not to so for
instance olek thought yesterday i mean a
few days ago about random spanning trees
uh and sort of the cover time barrier to
getting a near linear time algorithm for
uh for a random spanning tree sampling
uh okay but i mean today we'll see some
things which are sort of relevant to the
fact that that barrier doesn't really
exist
and also i guess richard uh in the last
workshop talked about joining work with
dan on uh
on on sampling from the gaussian field
in parallel time but without using the
words gaussian free fuel
oh i see my apologies sorry uh
but the comment still stands
okay uh so one question we can ask is
what i mean what do we expect
spectrograph theory to be good for and
and one thing we all know it's good for
is if you have some kind of operator
like a heat flow operator a random walk
on a graph uh and you want to look at
the
sort of the long time behavior of that
operator then obviously the thing to do
is diagonalize it
uh you look at in the in the spectral
basis and uh and then you can see lots
of things how how fast it converges to
uniform things that stop it from
spreading out in the material
i actually have now
as dan pointed out this is a
this is a touch see we'll see if this
works oh okay so like here's a this is a
body with some initial heat uh
configuration and then you know okay
this is the heat flow in the torus all
right but uh the point is that aside
from the mouse pointer
you know we're nobody surprised that uh
that spectrograph there has something to
say about this process hopefully at this
point we're not surprised
uh
okay
okay so how much can you say i mean you
know spectrograph theory is not magic so
you can't say anything you want
i mean the alternate title this thought
could be spectrograph theory is magic
but uh
so i mean suppose you wanted to instead
of considering sort of the bulk behavior
of the heat flow just consider the
trajectory of one particle okay so like
just random walk uh on the graph
it doesn't make sense that that that
sort of spectral method should let you
say something specific about this one
trajectory okay i mean it doesn't make
sense for lots of reasons but just like
from a physical perspective if you think
about the way heat disperses as sort of
like tiny vibrations you know uh giving
small amounts of energy to nearby
particles then there's sort of uh
anonymity like if two particles bump
into each other somewhere their
histories don't matter how they go off
from there is sort of you know you don't
name the particles and then keep track
of your favorite ones so
by the way i'm i was uh expecting maybe
some objections here but if there are
none
okay so
uh yeah so you know suppose we wanted to
say something at a single trajectory
okay in some sense that's an
embarrassing question because like a you
know spectral message shouldn't uh
shouldn't be able to talk about such
things okay so let me just now say uh
give a specific question about
considering a single
kind of trajectory and that's uh
about the cover time of a graph okay so
we have a graph g
w is the random walk on g
and uh
this random time tile curve is the first
time at which you know you start the
random walk it visits many vertices this
is a random time it's the first time in
which every vertex of g has been visited
so really keeping track of one particle
waiting until it has seen every single
vertex and then we stop that's talk of
and then the cover time is just the
expected value of talk of
okay except for the fact that there's a
we didn't specify the initial vertex for
the walk so
by convention although you'll see it
won't matter too much we'll take the
starting vertex to be the the sort of
the worst one the one from which the
expected time to cover is the is the
largest okay so this is the cover time
of a graph
and uh i mean already you can see that
this is a bit of a subtle parameter so
for instance for the complete graph
you know the random walk mixes in one
step
uh but if you want to cover the graph it
takes n log n steps this is just coupon
collecting i mean uh you know after n
steps naively you expect to you should
have seen everyone in expectation but of
course to to really get the last guy
he's very tricky to visit the last one
so you put his extra log n to do that
uh and then i mean you can also just
consider sort of the opposite end of the
spectrum which is the end cycle so there
the cover time is about n squared which
is on the order of the of the mixing
time so sort of uh
you know sort of like there you cover
about the same time that you mix here
here you mix in one step and it takes
you a very very long time to cover and
in general you can think about graphs
which are
you know various combinations of these
graphs at different scales and you get
some kind of complicated behavior okay
so uh okay so there are many things
known this parameter was studied
uh for quite a long time so for instance
uh as olek pointed out you missed my
comment about you in the introductory
remarks
you'll have to ask someone else about it
uh yeah so the the cover time is always
bounded by twice the number of edges
times number of vertices and uh feiga
showed that uh for any connected graph
uh
sort of it always takes at least n log n
time to cover the graph so here are some
generic bounds and let me just mention
two questions that indicate at least uh
up to a few years ago some some
some gaps in our understanding of cover
time so there's a question of aldous and
phil from the from the 90s which just
asks uh okay certainly i can compute the
cover time of a graph just by simulating
the random walk we saw in the previous
slide that you you know it takes at most
n cube steps uh in expectation so we
simulate the random walk and we output
you know okay do it 10 times take the
take the median or the average of uh of
the cover times and you can output this
as an approximation for the cover time
but you can ask you can do it
deterministically so in fact like most
classical
parameters of the random walk it was
known i mean it's not hard to see that
you can sort of compute them
deterministically
uh but this one this one sort of uh
appeared to be more difficult okay so
this is one question that they asked and
uh here's a here's the question of
winkler and zuckerman which is uh
uh so if you look at this coupon
collecting problem on the complete graph
so you're just doing random walk on a
complete graph then uh
okay so it takes you n log n steps
before you see every vertex but then if
you go another you know say n log n
steps actually you've seen every vertex
uh a proportional number of times every
vertex has been visited log n times
after say two n log n steps okay so the
conjecture is actually this is just true
for every graph for every graph uh if
you go to the cover time and then go a
bit more not only do you cover all the
vertices but you cover them equitably so
here it says it's sort of like you know
the blanket time is the first random
time t such that every vertex has been
visited say half as much as it should
have been visited according to the
stationary measure at that vertex okay
so they conjectured that uh
these two you know if you go if you go
into your cover then a little bit
further and you actually uh cover the
graph right sort of uniformly so those
are two two questions uh okay yeah so at
this point uh i wanted to give okay so
now the second uh
more impressive uh
okay
okay here's
uh there's some kind of scaling issue
which is why these numbers are on top of
each other okay so here we're just
watching the random walk cover the
taurus just like as a yeah can you
compute mixing time in the time depends
what you mean by mixing time but since
you can compute all the eigenvalues
well you can compute it depends what you
mean by the mixing time but you can
compute all the eigenvalues i mean yes
you can just power the adjacency matrix
we're using repeated squaring and then
you see what the distribution is so
uh okay we're covering the taurus here
it's actually going very fast my
computer is very fast today
uh
wow this is incredibly fast
maybe i was downloading updates all
night okay uh
okay but you see it's like very now we
have one vertex left to cover i don't
know where it is it's somewhere in here
uh
but the point is it's a
okay we didn't you know if you if you
watched the whole thing while i was
talking you see that you know sort of
the way in which you cover the tourists
is actually quite complicated and what
happens is sort of uh sometimes actually
don't make any progress and then
sometimes you get to a area you haven't
visited before and you cover an entire
clump and then at the very end of the
process you have a few stragglers and
it's taking you know some time to go
around and collect them okay so that was
that's just a
picture of the
cover what does the color mean yeah
sorry the yeah the coloring is just
proportional to the number of times it
was visited so another thing that
happens here is that you know at the
cover time you know some many guys were
visited a few times there are some hot
spots of people who were visited many
times
the conjecture of winkler and zuckerman
says that if we ran this for 150 000
steps then the color should be very
uniform
after we finish
okay
all right okay so
uh i convinced you maybe that the cover
time is a cool thing to study and uh
that maybe spectral technique shouldn't
have much to say about it
i don't know okay so uh fortunately for
us uh
uh dembo paris rosenzaytuni actually
computed uh like at least for the taurus
the cover time uh asymptotics exactly
okay so the cover time of so here little
n is the side length capital n is the
number of vertices so capital line is
little n squared
i get it right you've all right
is it a half and you square and you
divide by two okay
uh
yeah so so this is the the cover time of
the
of the capital n node taurus
uh
okay
i guess the pie is not to you know it's
a taurus
i mean you know if you if i if you go to
the matlab code where to
produce the tourist there's a pie so
uh
in fact
this bound was conjectured before you
proved it right so i mean it didn't so
this is conjectured by aldis yeah all
this proved one side of the bound uh the
upper bound
it's always the easier side so it must
be okay
not because all this only proves easy
things just because
the paper is uh has quite technical
estimates to prove this
uh okay so uh
i don't know now let's just sort of
blindly forge ahead and uh and uh write
down some spectral objects okay so let's
write that let's say l is the is the
laplacian energy just this this is the
diagonal degree matrix this is the
adjacency matrix of the graph g
and uh
okay everything except for the third
line here is everybody is comfortable
with v1 through vn are the eigenvectors
of l the only thing we need from this is
that v1 is the
is the is the constant eigenvector and
lambda one is equal to zero okay and uh
and then in addition to these uh
spectral objects we're gonna we have a
sequence of n id normal zero one random
variables okay and so let's just write
down
a random sum here's a random sound
okay
uh
you know we're just going to push around
symbols so they i mean yeah i was
working with like with david store last
night and he said you know we're just
pushing around symbols okay so that's
what we're going to do now
okay so this is the random somewhere
right the vi's are eigenvectors the gi's
are random normal zero one random
variables uh and the lambda i's are the
eigenvalues and we we don't divide by
zero because we only sum from two
that's a random sum okay so let's uh now
just take the maximum entry in that
random sum okay so this is a n
dimensional vector uh we look at the
maximum entry let's square it and
multiply by the number of edges in the
graph you just you know these are all
the things you know so you just put all
the okay so you put them all in a
formula okay and uh
all right that's a nice formula uh okay
miraculously
uh it turns out so here here i said
equals but i'll explain equals in a
second because this is a random number
uh
okay but uh well definitely the expected
value of this thing is uh is equal to
this up to a little of one factor so
this little of one is something that
goes to goes to zero as n goes to
infinity and uh
but also this is this is very highly
concentrated so sort of like the
variance of this thing also fits inside
the little of one factor
so so basically you do this random
experiment you'll get it you'll get a
a very nice estimation for the cover
time okay so this you know so now you're
saying well look i'm not very surprised
you said you can't do it spectrally
and then you gave me the taurus which is
this very symmetric object and then you
wrote down some formula i mean stuff
like this happens all the time because
you have tons of symmetries and so forth
but the amazing thing is that this
phenomenon is true completely generally
in any graph okay so here's the theorem
that we proved with the gian and evol a
few years ago
so you take now any graph g take the
same setup as before l is laplacian v
i's are the eigenvectors lambdas of the
eigenvalues
now compute this random vector
take the maximum entry square it and
multiply by the number of edges in any
graph this uh is proportional to the
cover time up to some
absolute constants okay yeah can you
show that it actually there has to be
some conspiracy one
okay good question all right we will
come to this uh
momentarily yeah
uh
so but but uh as long as you want
something of constant order then sort of
this kind of uh yeah seemingly
miraculous at the moment we're gonna
explain it that's the point of the talk
random experiment
by the way it will still be miraculous
at the end of the talk i would say that
it's still uh
no one quite really understands what's
going on uh
yeah so this this is proportional to the
cover time
and uh
and one nice thing okay just let me just
say for sort of computationally you can
sample from this uh
from this sort of uh you can sample this
random variable in nearly near time
using i mean this this occurs in a paper
of
dan and uh nikhil uh but basically you
can yeah you could there's you can
sample from this in the linear time
using laplacian system solvers okay
we'll see that in a second that you can
do that so
uh but just as a as a okay it's not
necessarily so impressive we replaced
one random you know this is a this is a
an expectation of a random quantity this
is an expectation of a random quantity
but this quantity has tons of structure
so for instance you can use it to
resolve these questions before so it
says uh
it gives you a deterministic algorithm
for approximating the cover time simply
because
there you can get a deterministic
algorithm if i give you the vi's and
lambda i's
you can get a deterministic algorithm to
approximate uh this infinity norm within
a constant factor and uh
and also you have to see that it comes
out from the proof but once you have
this set up you can you can you can
conclude that also the blanket time and
cover time are within a constant factor
okay so you get some structural i mean
you get some properties from this not
just sort of an amazing uh coincidence
of numbers
okay uh oh yeah i should say that sort
of uh
yeah the best previous bounce for both
of these were log log n due to khan kim
lovas and vu so they gave a log log n
approximation and they showed that these
two things are within log log n factors
for an endnote graph
uh okay but here here we get universal
constants
uh okay so now uh to lx question is the
constant bigger than one or maybe it's
uh really uh
only one so in the paper actually prove
that on the upper bound side you have
something uh
very precise so you you bounded by this
thing plus this and now i want to talk
about for a second that you should think
about this as an error term okay and the
idea is just that uh
you know in most interesting families of
graphs the cover time will be
asymptotically larger than the hitting
time okay so only basically in sort of
like one-dimensional examples do you
have that the cover time and hitting
time are on the same order okay and so
whenever the whenever we have a sequence
of graphs where the cover time is uh is
is asymptotically larger than the
hitting time meaning that you know the
cover time is less interesting if the
only if the reason it takes you a long
time to cover the graph is just because
it takes you a long time to get from one
vertex to another
so
uh you know sort of in most families of
graphs the reason it takes a long time
to cover is not just because it takes
you a long time to go between two fixed
vertices okay there's something more
complicated going on so if that's if
that's the case then uh then this this
is a little of one term with respect to
the cover time right so
okay so then you should so this is a
term which is
for
you know in some sense in the regime
where the cover time is interesting so
it's actually the regime where the cover
time is is concentrated uh sort of uh
then uh this this goes to zero so this
is little one
and uh and the engion a couple of years
after maybe just a year later uh proved
that actually for a wide class of graphs
you can match this uh this upper bound
so for bounded degree graphs and trees
uh
you can you can you can sort of get a
matching uh lower bound but now where
this constant c depends on the degree
the maximum degree in the graph
okay so this is a
this is really very nice and uh
and then this year
actually uh alex jai a student at
stanford showed that uh
you don't have to pay something
depending on the degree it's just the
case that for every graph
uh the cover time and this quantity are
within sort of this uh error term
okay so something which goes you know
again for for
interesting families of graphs when the
cover time is an interesting phenomenon
goes to zero as the
as the size of the graph goes to
infinity this error term is it real or
is it architectural analysis no the
error term is real um
actually forgot who uh this this occurs
in a paper of i guess uh uh
the toonie and jian or foreign i mean in
particular they do a calculation where
the the second order asymptotics are
really different
so it's uh
that's real
which kind of makes it even more
interesting phenomena and that's really
like does the error term actually scale
pretty much like that or is that a
cruder estimate
uh
in a specific there's a specific family
of graphs in which the error term does
scale exactly like this
what is this what was the enlightenment
yeah what is this example of a graph
where this accepted the enhancement
uh
okay good question
i you've already done just even
even for a tree
definitely on the on the two-dimensional
grid they did they do this on the taurus
what happens for the second order for
for the regular trees do you remember
i think there you also get to see it i
mean it should be the same as the taurus
so uh okay
so it should be the case that even for
you for the regular tree you get the
you get the second order
different difference okay okay so good
so now at this point in time that's what
this is what you should ask okay so what
is what what is this
do you have
do you have examples of a graph in which
the second order term is comparable
and
you really it's really like it's really
the bad case for it but that's really
you get this you can if you take a cycle
then the second or then the second order
term is comparable to the cover time
and
the problem is there you don't even have
concentration of the cover time the
cover time is in some sense no longer a
well-defined quantity for instance the
vert vertex you start at
starts to matter when you have uh
when uh when the heating time and the
cover time are the same order
somehow you
know the cover time it ceases to be sort
of the you know it's a robust quantity
as long as the cover time is
asymptotically larger than the hitting
times when it's not
yeah
yeah there it's not the starting point
but no the starting point doesn't matter
for the cycle but for the you know for
like a lollipop or something you can
you can get the starting point to matter
a lot for this for the cycle it's just
lack of concentration that you i mean
the the point at which you cover is you
know the expected value is since it's
not concentrated it somehow loses some
of its meaning
okay i mean this is this is you know
this is
half satisfying explanation
but it's but this is really what happens
from the
like i mean this is the real phenomenon
so
uh okay so now we want to say what is
this uh random sum okay so this random
sum is the gaussian free field on the
graph
uh okay so let's uh so let's now define
it just uh from uh first principles you
take a graph you fix some vertex v0 this
is where you ground the field okay
and then the gaussian field is the
unique centered gaussian process okay
centered means that these are all going
to be mean 0 normal random variables
calcium process means that
these are jointly normal random
variables so every linear combination of
them is again uh has is normally
distributed and
grounded at v zero just means that you
you just fix it somewhere so g of v zero
is equal to zero and then the thing
which specifies that you know it's a
gaussian process so once you once
actually yeah so so it's specified
completely by its covariant by the
covariances okay so now the covariances
are given actually by the effective
resistance distance in the graph so
expected uh gu minus gv squared is the
effective resistance distance between
um
oh yeah and uh yeah so by the as i said
earlier by these results of uh dylan
you can actually you can actually
construct vectors that approximately
give you this
uh in near linear time so the
that seems you can actually construct
the the all the vectors that seem
surprising because uh you know the the
natural description of these things it
has n vectors in an n-dimensional space
but since you know that johnson linden's
trials will move you to a log and
dimensional space and preserve
uh your distances then you can use this
to find the succinct representation of
the process which is not going to be
exactly the same but we'll have you know
some one plus epsilon here which body
which is one plus epsilon is sufficient
so that for instance the maximum value
also doesn't change by more than one
plus epsilon
uh okay good here there's another way to
say this which is in terms of in terms
of sort of sort of the uh
you know the
measure which is that uh
uh the density of this process is uh is
exactly sort of like you know the the
probability of seeing some configuration
is inverse exponential in the energy of
the configuration right so the
configuration is trying to make
the random variables be close along
edges
but you know
it's also just saying that it's
covariance matrix is the inverse
composition right yes that's the same
thing
uh yeah the covariance matrix is the
inverse laplacian
at a high level you're taking the effect
resistance and betting of the graph in
the high dimensional space and then
you're doing a perturbation by gaussians
right no no the this is the effective
resistance embedding uh you you can if
you set all the g's to identically one
or something no no so if you
no no you can you can think of these
these uh these these i i've specified
specify them as a random variable but
you can think about them just as vectors
you can think about them as vectors in
an dimensional space and then uh
and and then it's exactly the effective
resistance betting and the way you
sample from the process is you just
project on a random direction and that
will give you the realization
of the of the g's and that's the
algorithm right well the the
to sample from this process you take the
you take the effective resistance
embedding and you project on a random
direction that's the
what i'm saying they're the same thing
every gaussian processes you know on end
points is is exactly the same thing as
an endpoint subset of euclidean space
but you're right it is it's the
effective resistance
embedding uh on the graph
uh and okay so here and here's one
example uh like if you're if you just
take your graph to be a path and you
ground it at the first vertex then the
gaussian free field is just uh it's just
simple random is this trajectory is a
simple random lock so here's our here
these are many different samples from
the gaussian free field on a 10 000 node
path
is it easy to see that this effective
resistance satisfies the triangle
inequality
uh no it doesn't from this formula it's
not i mean there's there's no reason
that that expected g minus gv squared i
mean generally will not satisfy triangle
inequality if you just give me a
gaussian process
this is a special kind of gaussian
process
yeah my question was
is it easy to see how that happens
no no it's it's still easiest to see
from the right hand side that it
satisfies triangle inequality
it's easiest from the commute time
yeah so i mean the the effective
resistance is is uh is up to a scaling
by the number of edges in the graph the
same as the commute time between u and v
i guess that's the easiest way to see
that it satisfies triangle inequality
because
if you think about it obviously uh
okay you get it for free uh
but no i i don't uh
i mean yeah so this representation
doesn't give it to you because there are
other gaussian processes for which you
don't have this sort of square triangle
inequality triangle inequality for the
square distance so
and uh
actually i'm not sure about the other
way if you have a gaussian process which
is which
which uh for which the square declining
distance does satisfy the triangle in
quality i don't know if it's an
effective resistance
all right
yeah i don't know
it's not it's not
you know an example
is your
uh
okay so now uh i see all right we
discussed yesterday
okay so now we can restate what we said
before in terms of this gaussian free
field you take the graph g you take the
gaussian free field the cover time is is
uh
equal to the expected maximum squared uh
up to this uh error term okay and uh and
here sort of the grounding of the field
is gone because the expected maximum
it's easy to see it doesn't depend since
everything is mean zero it doesn't
depend on where you ground the field so
okay so what it's saying is that if you
if you want to sort of uh
uh compute the cover time one way to do
it is to sample from the gaussian free
field this is actually a grouse
synthetic field on a grid it's actually
grounded at the entire boundary of the
grid but
uh and then and then you look at sort of
the highest peak
and this gives you the you know sort of
these events the highest peaks
correspond to somehow to the time at
which the first time in which the graph
is uh is covered
uh
yeah and uh and another interesting
point is that you know uh raghu mecca
showed that you can actually you know
you can deterministically for instance
get a hold of this quantity uh very
accurately
using some de-randomization techniques
okay so uh
so let's see so now what's the what
should we do well obviously now we
should explain uh
uh sort of why
gaussian processes are relevant here
okay
so this requires this uh
dinkin isomorphism theory okay this is
just a book about the theory
uh okay so first we need the definition
of local times
uh so before we had the discrete time
random walk now we'll switch to
continuous timer in the block so it's
the same as the three time random walk
except that we just wait an exponential
amount of time at the vertex before we
before we jump
the sequence of jumps is exactly the
same as a discrete time walk we're just
you know we're just spending a random
amount of time out of vertex before we
move on okay and then uh so now given a
time t and a vertex v the local time at
v
uh
is is just uh i've written it here in
words because i think it's easier by the
way it's just the total time spent at
the vertex v up to time t normalized by
the amount of time you would have
expected to spend there in the
stationary measure which is proportional
as a degree okay so this is the you know
the relative amount of time proportional
to the amount of time you expected to
spend at the node that you've you've
been at that node up to time t
it's uh it corresponds to these colors
in the
in the taurus animation we had before
okay so uh
so there's been a lot of work uh
doing interesting things with local
times work of ray and knight in the 60s
sort of studying uh local times for
brownie and motion and then what we're
gonna do today is inspired by work of uh
or c today uh which is inspired by work
of thinking uh where there's sort of a
general connection between markov
processes and
and uh and gaussian fields
and in fact okay so what we're gonna so
what i'm gonna say now is what's called
the generalized secondary knight theorem
by uh eisenbaum caspian marcus rosen and
she
which is basically a a generalization of
of some version of the ray knight
theorem for brownian motion but to the
setting of general markov processes in
particular random locks on graphs okay
here we go
okay
so okay so we fixed the vertex v0 and
now we're going to define this time so
what do we do uh
basically we're going to instead of
thinking about global time we're going
to parameterize everything by the amount
of time we spend at the node v zero okay
so
uh t of l is the first time this is a
random number at which we've we've uh
we've we've spent time l at v zero
okay so we fix the node v zero we start
doing random walk
t of l is the first time at which we've
we've actually been at v zero for time l
uh okay and also let's let's take the
gaussian free field on the graph uh
uh
rounded at v zero
okay so now here's the isomorphism
theorem for every l
okay the following holds okay so uh so
let's let's take this a little slowly we
have two processes here one on the left
one on the right both are our random
fields both are uh n variate random
variables okay with one variable for
every for every vertex uh
uh i mean the two sides are independent
it's like you should think about them as
separate probability spaces and also on
this side we have two things we have a
we have a a gaussian and we have a local
time those are also independent okay so
that's the i didn't write you know the
slide is already has enough words on it
but the the over here for this random
process these two things are independent
okay and the claim is that for every l
if you look at the you know for if you
look at the field of local times plus
some gaussian
squared perturbations then uh
then that process is the same as the a
process which has no local times and
just has gaussians so you you shift the
gaussians and you square
okay when we say same we mean same in
the very very very strong sense that
these are identical in law these are
really the same processes yeah so should
i be treating these i'm trying to
understand the set notation as a
distribution or as vectors yeah you
should treat themselves as n-dimensional
vectors okay so this is a this is a very
strong statement this is not saying that
you sample one this is really saying
that uh well actually they're the same
statement but uh
the joint distributions are the same
right okay uh
yeah so the the joint law on our end if
n is number of nodes given by these two
things is is precisely the same law not
just uh you know
i mean really the same all right uh and
then here i just uh you know t here is t
of l i could have written tfl i will
actually in a few slides okay so this is
the this is the isomorphism theorem
ah
sorry miss did you say that the walk is
moving in continuous time
yes
uh
okay so this is the appropriate reaction
to the theorem uh and in fact okay so i
i put the book up earlier there's an
entire book written about these things
by um
by uh marcus and rosen and uh
one can prove these things in greater
and greater generality
uh
even the book itself confesses that that
that nobody really understands the
proofs
uh
so they say you know people ask us when
we give talks to if is there some
intuitive explanation for why the
isomorphism theorems hold and they you
know they say well this is a good
research project for the interested
reader okay
so and this will remain a mystery even
at the end of the talk yeah so what's
going on with v0 and how does the laws
change when v0 changes uh v0 is just a
matter of uh
well
so so uh i mean this side doesn't this
is this side when you're just you're
just translating when you when you
change v zero right you're just sort of
moving uh
you know
now over over on this side the
and the t changes
yeah yeah i mean the other side changes
more more drastically when you change v0
uh you know it's a little tricky because
you know in the these are identical in
law but sort of if you take the coupling
which we'll do in a second uh sort of
that makes them the same then of course
these have different distributions
the two g copies of g on the different
sides so
uh you only get sort of one side of the
the translation for free
okay uh all right that happens again
okay uh okay so just to understand this
and and how sort of amazing it is let's
just
see what happens for a graph with a
single edge
okay so have a graph with one edge has a
node v0 and a node v
uh
okay so then you know the this uh this
equality of law is is uh only has one
interesting thing in it it only has only
the v is interesting uh v zero obviously
at this at this time this is l for v
zero and this is zero and this is zero
so this side is also l so one part of
the law says that l equals l that's not
surprising to most of us
uh the only interesting thing is what
the law says about the about gv okay so
just something about one
random variable okay so what's the
distribution of gv well the effective
resistance between v zero and v is one
okay so so so this gv is just a
just a normal zero one random variable
okay so i'm just writing the right hand
side
uh
you know for gv it's just half a normal
zero one
shifted and n squared that's the that's
the right hand side so what we're doing
is we're just we're just seeing what the
process what this theorem says for a
single edge graph and in that case
there's only one interesting random
variable on the right hand side okay so
on the left hand side we we put the same
half x squared
uh and then uh okay then we need to
write down sort of what is the what is
the local time at v given that the local
time at v zero uh was l okay and this is
not so hard okay so what this is is so
when you start at v zero you do some
number of excursions to v like you come
to v for a while you go back you come to
v for a while you go back okay so
suppose m is the number of excursions
we'll specify m in a second then what's
the time we spend at v well just for
every excursion we spend an exponential
amount of time with mean one there
before we go back so okay so the so the
local time is the sum of iid
exponentials there's this m which we
didn't specify yet but the y i's are
just id exponentials m
is the number of excursions uh that we
make
before we've accrued time l at v zero so
it's the
also the amount of times we're putting a
v0 exponentials so the number of
exponentials you need to sum to get to l
is a poisson
with parameter l okay
so the
and all of these all these random
variables here are independent so so
even for the one edge case the
isomorphism theorem gives you the
following fact
which is due to pitman
much earlier
but if i take a normal if i take any
value l take a normal random variable
shift it and square it
then uh it has the same law as sort of
the you know uh half the normal squared
plus an iid
uh poisson as a poisson sum of iid
exponentials okay
and uh
okay even to prove this is uh
uh i guess it's an exercise in your
false book
uh
but uh
actually there's there's also no known
way to prove this uh that doesn't just
compute either the densities of both
sides or compute the moment generating
functions on both sides and then you
just see that they're equal
there's no you know it would be a it
would be great to give a coupling proof
of this that really shows you why the
two sides are equal because you can
think about them as sort of you know
doing some kind of
correlated sampling between two related
processes but there isn't one i actually
think this is that this this this was a
actually would say now that this is a
a bit of a red herring because
i think that the correct way to prove
the isomorphism theorem is to just take
this fact on faith this is like a fact
about the world and then uh
you know and but then the fact that it
leads to a law i mean this is uh this is
already a remarkable fact but it's not
nearly as remarkable as the fact that a
joint law on end things has the same you
know joint law on some other end things
right that this you know okay somehow
that's this is much more remarkable but
okay i don't know philosophically i
would say that uh
actually i don't think that the right
way to understand the proof of this
thing is to first understand the proof
of this really well
i i can if somebody's interested they
can ask afterwards why i say that
i was hoping i would have a the next
slide would be the would it be the
theorem that explains it but it didn't
happen yet
okay uh
yeah so this is the this is the the full
theorem again and let me just say very
briefly before i go on to tell you why
this gives a
uh a proof let me just say very briefly
about how
the our original proof uh went
um
okay so the point is that uh
you know
you can you can you can think about the
cover time maybe it's not even necessary
to write it down you know the cover time
is the first uh
is the first t at which all the local
times are bigger than zero right that's
the
that's that's the first time we visited
every node when all the local times are
bigger than zero uh
so if you want to prove that the cover
time is at most the expected maximum of
this free field uh
that's actually
um
not so hard
because if you choose this free field so
that the expected maximum is large
enough okay then you can be assured that
the right hand side is going to be large
okay like uh choose choose this this
term to be like
you know some small constant times the
expected maximum then this side the
right hand side will be uh
wait what this that didn't make any
sense what do i want to say
oh yeah sorry sorry sorry and i said i
just said it the wrong order choose this
side to be the expected maximum and then
no sorry choose this side to be sort of
like greater than the expected maximum
okay so that no gv could possibly get
there okay
the expected maximum of the gaussian
process is very concentrated so if you
choose this to be greater than the
expected maximum none of these things
can possibly get there so every term on
the right-hand side would be positive
okay and if you choose it large enough
then you can just see that all of these
are like noise terms so everything here
is positive
these are tiny so all of these will be
positive okay this is the way you prove
the cover time is at most the expected
maximum
square okay that's uh
uh
that's not so hard the more difficult
thing is to prove the the lower bound uh
so to prove the lower bound we want to
say okay we go to some time and if we
didn't get to the cover time yet no
sorry if the time is smaller than the
expected maximum squared we want to say
that one of these should be zero so if
you just look at this law and your goal
is to get one of the local times to be
zero i mean what can you do
one thing you can do is you can try to
you know set it up so that the gaussian
field you know gets some element very
close to this value right like you know
this is just like uh you know somehow gv
you want to get some gv that's very
close to this value then this side will
have some very small value and maybe if
this side is small enough you can argue
that uh
that it forces this to be zero okay
this is not meant to be understandable
just that sort of like it makes sense
that if you want something on this side
to be small you should try to get
something on this side to be small
and so then we do a lot of technical
work to try to analyze sort of second
order properties of of the maximum of
gaussian fields to say that if this is
near the maximum then actually you you
can get some point very close to it so
then you get something here which is
very small and then you get something
small on the other side that was it's a
technical proof and uh
and i'm not sure there's
at least from this perspective much
reason to read it anymore
uh
okay because uh because of this new
proof of uh
of alex okay so so uh
uh jian made the following conjecture uh
in his paper
um
which is uh i mean it looks similar all
the objects are the same as the
isomorphism theorem but it's uh okay but
it's it's not the same it's not quite
the same so on the left-hand side we
still have all the local times but now
we take their square roots and on the
right-hand side we have you know
in some sense you just take the square
root of both sides of this thing
uh okay but uh you know you need to be
careful not to take square root of a
negative number or something i mean i
don't i don't know but no so uh
uh you take square root of both sides
and then you want sort of some kind of
domination okay and this green thing
here means stochastic domination
yeah
what jen
said the point is not square root of a
negative number because they have
positive i said i i i made a comment to
myself that this was a this was not as
that was the point square root you don't
want to take
right so you cannot take square root of
both sides that we're trying to say yeah
of course yeah you cannot just you
cannot like just uh i mean the first
thing you try to do on day one is is
expand the square and then cancel off
the half gv squared from both sides but
that's not you're not allowed to do that
with these things so
okay uh so this is this is the
conjecture where this means uh this is
stochastic domination so it really means
that there should be a coupling of these
two processes where the
i don't know okay it doesn't
ignore that picture for now a couple of
these two processes where the left hand
side in this coupling always sits below
the right hand side
okay so it's sort of saying that there's
a that you can get the values here to to
dominate the values in the left-hand
side and this is really nice because now
if you want to get a if you want to get
something on this side to be zero you
just need to get some gaussian to be
smaller than minus square root two l you
go from the problem of trying to get
some gaussian to be exactly a quantity
which is some second-order thing that's
very hard to control so just trying to
say that you get a gaussian that's
smaller than some height
okay so you know what it what it would
say is that if you uh
if you uh this green thing is supposed
is a is a is a abstract inter you know
picture of the gaussian free field it
says that if you sample from the galaxy
energy field and then you look at this
line minus square root 2 l and you look
at all of the gvs that fall below this
line then these precisely correspond to
uncovered
nodes of the graph
so there exists a coupling between the
random walk and the gaussian field such
that when you sample from the field
everything below the line minus square
root 2 l are uncovered sets of vertices
in the graph this is the conjecture it's
very audacious because jian only proved
it for trees and
for trees the proof is is is not so easy
it's pretty simple and and not at all
generalizable okay but john made the
conjecture and okay and uh
and uh alex solved the conjecture and so
now in the last five uh to ten minutes
let me try to say how how you can uh how
you can prove this
domination
using of course the isomorphism theorem
so using an isomorphism theorem you
prove this domination
all right
okay uh and i should mention that uh
alex's work appeared slightly after
slash concurrently with depending on how
you measure time
and uh
a result of lupu which which does not
sort of uh which doesn't prove this but
the technique for proving it is in is
also in lupus paper
okay so uh what does alex do okay so you
start with the graph and now you want to
have the gaussian field on the graph
so the first thing he does which is
you know somehow the main step of the
proof
is the is that yeah okay so so you
replace every edge of the graph by uh an
interval of length one so you make the
graph into a one-dimensional simplicial
complex okay so now it went from being a
discrete set to now a continuous a
continuous object and now instead of
doing random walk on the graph we're
going to do brownie in motion on this
continuous object
so so if you if you do brownian motion
here and you stop it at the vertices
then
what you see is exactly the continuous
time random lock
okay so sort of the
if we if we ignore the fact that the
edges now have uh some life of their own
what we see at the vertices is just
going to be the same thing but the
advantage here is now that when you look
at the
the corresponding uh gaussian free field
so now the galaxy field is on this
continuous object okay it's so now the
okay
so now the sort of the set of vertices
is a is a continuous set but uh just
from basic properties of gaussian
processes this gauss entry field is is
continuous on this object so it means
that now the you know before they were
the gaussians were just values sitting
up here but now i claim that when you
sample and you get a value for every
point of the continuous graph that uh
the resulting field is continuous
this is going to be the key to the to
the proof okay
uh so what you do is you take this
continuous object the gaussian diffusion
on the on the on the
the simplicial complex and then you
apply the
you apply the isomorphism theorem to
that so the isomorphous theorem is quite
general it also works for you know for
this kind of object
uh so now you get the same thing i'm
writing it the same way but now the
point is that this these these v's are
living on the on the continuous graph
okay uh okay sorry in this transition i
did two things i moved the graph over
and also uh
i gave the thing on the left-hand side a
different name so now this is gv hat and
this is gv just to so that it's clear
that they're not the same thing okay so
now uh
so now our goal is to use this
for the continuous graph to prove this
thing uh
that we this stochastic domination for
the
uh for the original set of vertices and
uh i i knew that i was going to run out
of room on the slide so uh okay so
here's the whole proof the proof is like
the proof is not going to take the next
uh
we'll go slowly and it will take the
next two minutes
okay so the first thing you do is uh
these these two things are identical in
law so
and and on on this side these two things
are independent so what you do is just
take the coupling uh between gv and gv
hat that makes the two sides equal okay
so now we'll take a joint probability
measure on the two sides such that these
two products are exactly equal okay uh
you know and now the marginals of gv and
gv hat are are gaussian but they could
have some very complicated
dependencies between them
and then we define this function so i'll
just write it again here so it's a
function on the
on the continuous graph
which is uh
gx what's i'm using plus here
minus gx hat
okay
that's the that's the function and now
we just here's here are some properties
of the function
the first thing is that i claim that the
function is continuous okay and that's
because of the thing we already said
that both of these
fields are almost surely continuous so
the f of x is almost surely continuous
okay so f is
continuous
um
and uh
and then the other important property is
that if f of x equals zero
okay what does that imply so if if this
thing equals zero it means that that
this is equal to this okay so if you so
it means that the square of this is
equal to the square of this thing
uh which means that the corresponding
local time is zero because this term
equals this term and this is positive so
it has to be zero so the claim is that
if f of x equals zero then
uh the corresponding local time
is equal to zero
okay
so that's the
okay so now that's the
so look at this domination and see what
we need to show uh
if there's a if there's a local time
that's now we really want to show when i
say domination now that we've made them
have the same law we want to use this
exactly this law to get the domination
so now we really just want to show that
every value here is at most the
corresponding value there
that's our goal to show the domination
if a value here is zero then we're fine
we're in good shape this side is
positive i mean it's not negative so so
if if something here is zero we don't
have to show anything okay the only
interesting thing is when these things
are not for the non-zero things over
here are they dominated by this side
okay
so let's just uh okay so let's define
u
to be the set of
uh x's such that uh
fx is uh sorry that the local time is
bigger than zero
okay
these are the set of things on the
left-hand side that we need to worry
about because they're not trivially
dominated by the right-hand side
and if you think about what we want to
show here
we want to show that
on this set f is positive because if f
is positive it exactly says that uh
yeah sorry um
good uh if f is positive exactly says
that this is bigger than this
so
uh
let's see this is bigger than this
then you go to the isomorphisms here
yeah you're down down here uh so this is
bigger than this means that the
means that the square root of the local
time is uh
one over ah okay so you uh
yeah okay you i mean it's actually for
some reason a little trickier than i
thought you take square root of both
sides and then use the fact that this is
bigger than this uh
to get uh
uh you know to to show that this is you
know inside the square this is at most 1
over square root 2 times this basically
this when you take the square root you
get a half of this thing
the halves are correct here
so let's see sorry one second
i've done this like uh
made known
three times now in my life at this exact
point
managed to confuse uh
excuse myself
okay let's see all right
okay
we want to say that uh
if f is positive then we when then we
have uh
we have domination here
okay let's put it like a star by
my side
so
here uh f x greater than zero
uh
implies we're okay okay that's uh we
haven't verified this yet we'll come
back to it in a second uh
so okay suppose we knew that when fx fx
is bigger than zero then we have a
domination okay
this i know it's not a very convincing
thing at this point but the claim is
that uh the claim is that then we're
done because uh
we have a set u okay
uh
which is the things that are have been
visited so far we know that v0 is in you
i mean in particular we started the walk
at v zero
and uh and we know that f of v zero if
you if you calculate what it is uh it
scroll to l
okay which is bigger than zero so now f
at v zero is bigger than 0
we know that on this whole set f cannot
vanish because if f vanishes the local
time is 0.
so f is continuous it can't vanish on
the set and it's bigger than 0 at one
point so this implies that actually f is
bigger than 0 on the whole set
and this is where we use continuity and
now the only question is why was star
is star true and uh
so let me let me take this in the in the
coffee break okay and if you're watching
online i apologize uh it's an exercise
excellent
just
the point is when you take square roots
the only
problem you have to worry about is when
whether the right hand side is negative
gv plus root tl is negative because if
it's positive then taking the square
roots will will work
and and the fact that f is positive
rules out the possibility that
um
that
gv plus root tl is negative
why is the last fact true though that's
why is the f positive rule out the fact
that this is negative
what's inside the
the what's inside the square root
because then the identity
then the identity can't work
ah then then you would then you would
then then okay you're right so uh
um
if they were if they were both negative
then when you square you'll get
something larger than the right hand
side
okay so we'll still leave it as an
exercise
for the interested reader and uh say
that modulo that exercise then
then the proof is finished and i'll stop
there
if that's the end you guys can
flap if you want
okay so in in the in order to clarify
this i i would i mean if you really want
to understand it you should just read
well read section 3.1 of alex's paper uh
because the point is that despite the
fact that uh
i should have done it in two steps and
for some reason they decided to do it in
one step which makes it very confusing
the proof is very very simple and and
you really i mean the the big conceptual
thing is being used here is the fact
that f is continuous
and if you only saw f at the original
vertices this continuity is lost
like you don't i mean
you can't say that just because it's
positive somewhere uh and it can't be
zero that it you know it could still
yeah you can't say that you know that uh
it can't vanish just because of those
two things let me see if i get this
because this was i realized a point that
i almost missed because i was worrying
about how to prove the inequality you
were proving there which i i know except
it's probably just mechanical
um but right you're saying the key point
is by you're able to use right once you
have this continuous process
right on the ground
you control the words that it can't
vanish and but you don't control a
priority that it can't be negative but
the continuity allows you to
to show because at the v zero it's
positive that's another another key
point but why is every point on the same
side of the zero set as v zero good
question why is this set connected
that's what you're saying uh it's
obviously connected in the discrete time
case it's because it's just the things
that were visited you know starting at
v0 the fact that it's connected you know
so now all you really need is the fact
that sort of the
you know
the occupation set of brownian motion is
connected and this is
not i okay this is true and not hard but
but non-trivial fact
so it's just the fact that if you look
at the local time of ryan motion then
you know kind of normalized time you
spend at the no that can't vanish
inside the support
and this is not a trivial fact this is
known as ray's theorem and it's
connected back to the local time to you
know the early version of the ray knight
theorem which says that the local time
itself is the square of
in
absolute value of a planar branded
motion so there is a non-trivial
point there so for those wondering
what's going on i mean the question is
basically you know can the brownian
motion manage to go from you know can
the thing manage to go from here to here
but actually only spend time zero at an
intermediate point
and the point is
yeah i mean
you have to
you know
i mean yeah so can something in order
for brown in motion to spend a
non-zero time there it has to actually
you know
sit there for a second in some
normalized sense and the claim is just
said no it's brownian motion so it can't
just sort of like ballistically shoot
over this thing and keep going
you know when you zoom in it will it has
lots of variation so it will actually
end up spending time there but it's a
good
very good question yeah
after spending all this time worrying
about your work on the high dimensional
embedding of graphs
you know all the you know arb and all
that isn't there just an equivalent
statement of all this stuff as high
dimensional embeddings
and projections and stuff like that
because gaussians are just projections
and so yes aren't we just simply doing
something like embedding using the this
and then when you say it's continuous
it's because you want to look at
continuous embeddings and reach counted
at all in some simple
the continuous fact is is also not
trivial the fact that it's the fact that
the sample paths are
well you're doing continuous i mean
clearly you can move around under you
know what vector you're projecting it on
and do continue no no the the projection
the the sort of the projection could be
could be uh
no when you go to the continuous field
now you're in an infinite dimensional
space and the the the projection could
be unbounded like because uh it could be
that when you zoom in on this brownian
motion it's going you know in all kinds
of different directions so that when you
do this projection you you get some huge
yeah you could get some huge projection
so it's not it's not the case that uh
from the projection standpoint you see
that it's uh it's continuous and in fact
it's not conta i can give you sets of
vectors in in uh infinite dimensional
hilbert's space which for which the
corresponding process is not sample path
continuous
so they exist
these lines and that graph are not going
to be actual lines once you do this as
an objection they're going to be like
arbitrary paths right i don't know
but but yeah but but to say to answer
yes to your statement a different way of
saying is that if you want the cover
time take the effective resistance
embedding
project onto a random direction and take
the diameter of the projection
that will be the also the cover time
so okay much easier for you to think
that way but i mean you know i'm sorry
but but the proof is
that way though
just doing that or no one's seen it the
only way we know to prove it is with
this this isomorphism theorem which is
uh which is a mystery
so you really need this analytic these
analytic facts to
make this in this continuity no no you
can you can improve quantitative
versions of all those things and in fact
that's that's what alex does in the
paper
you uh
this is this qualitative proof you can
you can you can discretize it and make
it quantitative
but those are people who prove the
isomorphism theorem is it five moments
yeah
you compute the moment generating
function on both sides
on the left hand side since you have a
local time you end up with some kind of
feminine cats formula so you sum over
all the paths you know and all the
trajectories with appropriate
multipliers
you get something complicated you get
some binomial coefficients on the right
hand side uh you get sort of a you get
these moments of gaussians and if you if
you think about sort of like this wick
product formula moments of gaussians
involve uh like when you take products
of like uh sums of gaussians you know
the sort of in some sense the the odd
degree terms go away because you get uh
by because they're mean zero and you're
only left with even degree terms you end
up counting perfect matchings
okay so there's combinatorics on both
sides
that's the i mean that's the
and so if you work through them they're
the same common cards combinatorial fact
about perfect matchings being in
correspondence with something or no that
even that would be it would be nice if
there was a way to think about the
perfect matching that somehow related to
trajectories in the random walk
okay that
is an interesting question
thank you
you